Sesame Street debuted 45 years ago this
week 45 years ago okay now in honor of
this 45th birthday one member of the
cast is doing the responsible thing
ladies and gentlemen it's Ernie from
Sesame Street getting his first
colonoscopy
[Applause]
that's good Arnie good see Arnie it's
really good that you're doing this my
family history ok that's alright yeah
it's good to sign up for Obamacare yeah
yeah you should have done that a while
ago yeah dude website was confusing
yeah it's okay and you're on a lot of
meds fare I'm heavily sedated hey my
eyes are wide open wearing your shirt
still that's so weird
they take the shirt off I've had one of
those ah man I gotta say you're a little
guy that's a lot of tubing they're using
that burt is it you know what you think
are you okay though pal you doing good
okay all right well ladies and gentleman
I think we've seen enough of this I
think he's gonna be fun
oh my god we're losing him
I was in heaven you I was in heaven you
robbed me of eternal bliss you bastard
settle down you'll see you in hell you
son of a [ __ ]
you didn't want to die did you I was
with mr. who are eternal bliss we have a
great show quiet
you